a covid call today addressing the surge
in a new effort
focusing on minority populations 8 news
now reporter kristen drummond
listened to that call and reveals when
to expect this initiative
the nevada office of minority health and
equity plans to release a coveted
response tool kit
it aims to educate organizations focused
on addressing health needs of vulnerable
communities
the toolkit consists of four categories
a cultural literacy strategy
an outreach and public awareness
strategy a contact tracing
and emergency response strategy as well
as an action planning and reporting
strategy
the office wants staff to work with
groups across the state
to share the information to try and
reduce the spread among minority
communities
the hispanic community has been one of
the hardest hit with kova 19
in southern nevada campaigns like esta
and tusmanos aim to raise awareness
about the virus but
certain situations make it difficult to
control the spread
we know that here in the south we have a
propensity of casino activity
and the demographics of the employment
base does tend to lean towards
a minority population and because of the
inability to shelter in place we
continue to see that exposure the nevada
office of minority
health and equity planned to announce
next week when the toolkit will go live
on the state's department of health and
human services website
it may help as our positivity rate and
hospitalization numbers go
up the state expects the search to
continue because
of possible thanksgiving exposures there
are
16 of 17 counties flagged right now for
elevated disease transmission clark
county is included
and it's the eighth week in a row on
that list
back to you kristin thank you now there
is no date set for distribution of the
vaccine in our state of nevada but a
federal review is scheduled this
thursday
for the emergency use authorization of
pfizer
the other meeting is next week for
moderna the state says the outcomes will
direct when nevadans can start accessing
the vaccine